ray dalio is the 29th richest person in
america
with a net worth of 16.9 billion dollars
[Music]
but this hedge fund mogul wasn't always
the money maker he is now
dalio grew up in a middle class
neighborhood in hyde park long island
his father was a jazz musician and his
mother stayed at home helping to raise
her only son
and manage the household as a kid
dalio got his first taste of money while
caddying at the very exclusive
lynx club in long island you would
overhear the golfers trading stock tips
and thought it would be fun to play the
markets too
he only made five dollars for every golf
bag he carried
so that limited his investment options
but there was one stock selling for
under five dollars
northeast airlines he bought that
tripled his money and was instantly
hooked
he followed his drive to predict the
markets attending long island university
for undergrad
and getting his mba in finance from
harvard business school
after graduating he worked for two
different companies before deciding to
start his own
which he named bridgewater associates
and launched from his new york city
apartment in 1975.
just a few years later he appeared for
the first time in forbes magazine
interviewed at his 17-acre connecticut
farm
at the time he was managing 30 million
dollars with 44
employees for the record his drink of
choice was moosehead beer
and he graciously indulged our
photographers as he fed his horse
since then bridgewater has evolved into
the world's biggest hedge fund
now managing roughly 140 billion dollars
with over 1500 employees
dalio's famous for predicting the
housing and banking crisis
that sparked the great recession and
making money while other hedge funds
crashed in 2008
bridgewater is now the most profitable
hedge fund in history
the hedge fund manager has declared on
more than one occasion
that cash is trash and that gold instead
is his preferred asset for risk aversion
and his predictions have earned him
quite a lot dalio's been a regular on
forbes list for years
while amassing an absolute fortune but
he's not just sitting on it
rey and his wife barbara signed the
giving pledge in which they publicly
committed to giving the majority of
their wealth to philanthropy
they've donated over five billion
dollars to their dalio philanthropies
which supports ocean conservation public
schools
mental health and in a homage to his dad
even jazz music all in all
life turned out pretty great for this
one time five dollar bag golf caddy
you